So for this menu project, I want to
create an application where I can make
various restaurant menus with various
items, often within one application.
All restaurant menus in the general
sense contain the same thing.
Some have a few appetizers,
some entrees, a few desserts, and
of course some beverages.
To keep things simple, let's call
all of these things menu items.
And all of my menu items belong
to a specific restaurant menu.
It also would be helpful
to have a price and
brief description for
each of our menu items.
An important early design decision
to make is how to model my database.
There is more than one correct
way to structure a database, but
there is no need to make
things too complicated.
Let's walk through the process of
making a database layout together.
We have a restaurant table to represent
all of the restaurants in our database,
along with a corresponding name and
ID number.
Then we have a table of menu items.
Each menu item will have a name,
an ID, a description, a price, and
a course to categorize whether it is an
appetizer, entree, dessert or beverage.
We will also provide a restaurant
ID to assign a foreign key
relationship with our restaurant table.
Okay.
So
we've planned out how we
will design our database.
Now let's get to coding it up.
If you've used SQL before you might be
used to writing something like this.
If you're not an SQL expert it might
be a little hard to understand though.
Now there is nothing
wrong with this code, but
let's take a look at it for a second.
Using raw SQL we have this inquiries
to the database as strings.
This works, but our Python compiler has
no way of helping me if I make a typo or
reference a table that doesn't exist.
Every other data structure we use
in Python is some type of object.
So why not treat our database queries,
tables, and rows as objects as well.
Well this concern isn't a unique one,
and developers have created tools for
this very problem.
Object-Relational Mappers, or ORM's,
can be thought of like a translator.
Converting our code from
one form to another.
If we send off code written in Python or
any other preferred programming
language, it is transformed by the ORM
into SQL and sent off to our database.
The ORM also gets results
from an SQL statement and
allows us to use it as an object
from within our Python code.